et
[Musique]
appréciez le temps d'un voyage en train
regarder les paysages se succéder il
descendra baker qui font la taille d'un
arrêt de bus
rencontrer des gens partager leurs
histoires autour d'un verre échanger nos
idées et chanter ensemble toute une
soirée
[Musique]
nous ses jumeaux et esso et en juillet
2021 nous sommes partis à 2 sur les
routes de france pendant deux mois pour
découvrir les alternatives qui
fleurissent dans le pays qui rencontrent
les gens qui vivent d'un deseco village
ou habitats légers suivre des formations
et faire des chantiers participatifs
alors avant de partir on nous a demandé
pourquoi on faisait ce voyage ont
répondu naturellement pour découvrir les
échos lieu mettre la main à la pâte
transmettre aux gens ce que nous
apprenons et faire connaître les
alternatives à travers carnet de voyage
photo votre classe et reportages
nous lier quelque chose en plus qui nous
a poussé à partir quelque chose qu'on
explique pas tout de suite qu'on
comprend purin le convoyage quelque
chose qu'on assimile sûrement dernier
train
car il ya des mots qui résonnent des
sourires qui nous marquent des
rencontres aussi furtif chatel qui ne
s'oublie pas
pendant le voyage nous nous sommes
déplacés au gré de nos envies et des
contacts pris avant le départ et chaque
semaine on découvrait un lieu
merveilleux
respectueux de toutes formes de vie un
lieu plein de surprises la bienveillance
et est toujours maître mot et on
s'étonner de voir que si on ne peut y
avoir une semaine aussi fantastique que
la précédente
ce voyage c'était notre manière à nous
de recréer du lien de découvrir les
beaux visages de l'alternatif et de la
résilience ces gens qui sont passés par
une multitude de réflexion et de doutes
qui ont le courage de les construire
tout un mode de vie pour reconstruire un
nouveau plus juste et plus beau
[Musique]
c'était notre manière à nous de les
aider mais de participer à leur
émancipation et mettre notre énergie au
profit d'hommes et de femmes et et non
pas au profit de grandes multinationales
c'était notre manière à nous de
retrouver à ce poids dans un monde où
l'on souffre des camps dossier t2 manque
de sens de vouloir prouver qu'il faut
continuer de se battre car il y aura
toujours durant vingt secondes
c'était notre manière à nous de nous
écouter lui faire ce que l'on aime et
vous faire avec amour au total ce sont
une dizaine de lieux dans cette région
de france que nous avons découvert mais
ce sont surtout les centaines de
personnes que nous avons rencontrées
avec pour chacune d'elles une histoire
un sourire qui nous ont transportés bien
au-delà de ce que nous aurions imagine
alors si au travers de nos partage
podcast photoreportage et carnets de
voyage pouvant inspirer certains
en émerveiller d'autres aient participé
au récent champion du monde
alors notre part il sera rempli
alors faites ce que vous aimez
aimer ce que vous faites
c'était chez moi tu es sont au coeur des
écoliers bisous à plus
bonsoir bonsoir
même si vous
même si vous coupez avoir
regardé cette vidéo avec attention
bonsoir à toutes et à tous on est ravi
d'être là et on remercie toute l'équipe
de nous avoir invités
bah du coup devait un peu vous demander
qu'est ce qu'on vient faire là à parler
des échos lieu au beau milieu d'un tedx
sur l'invisible
et bien justement passé et qu'au lieu
tout comme beaucoup beaucoup
d'alternatives les projets qu'ils
remettent en cause notre système actuel
fait la plupart du temps s'est rendu
compte qu'ils étaient sains visibiliser
et quand on parler d'eux souvent c'était
de manière caricaturale et souvent
biaisée par exemple j'ai un peut grossir
le trait quand on parle des écovillages
on nous dit harlem et c'est une secte de
d'anarchistes marginale aux bobos hippie
qui vivent pieds nus et qui font l'école
à la maison bah nous quand on entend ça
ça siffle un peu dans nos oreilles du
coup bah on n'aura pas la prétention de
vous prouver le contraire par a plus b
mais juste si avec nos mots et nos
ressentis par rapport à ces lieux là on
pouvait essayer l'image qu'on peut avoir
de ces lieux est en fait vous montrer
comment ils participent au ré
enchantement du monde et nos imaginaires
et au final quels sont leur but commun à
tous
alors on va reprendre un petit peu du
début
solène l'année dernière elle faisait un
service civique et moi j'étais ici en
cinquième année et on s'est appelé
pendant le 2ème confinement et pendant
notre notre app et nos esprits ce sens
un peu enflammé et finalement le projet
est né et on était à un moment de notre
vie où on questionnait pas mal de choses
notamment notre diplôme son utilité
qu'est-ce qu'on allait en faire c'était
une période as you gêne pour nous aussi
en trombe à la crise la crise sanitaire
la crise environnementale les
problématiques sociales qu'avait et c
est en fait dans tout ce brouhaha là on
a vraiment on s'est vraiment poser les
questions de qu'est-ce que ça allait
être notre impact vous là dans lequel
roll on avait à jouer et donc on a voulu
pousser ce questionnement un peu plus
loin
et en parallèle de tout ça on avait le
projet avec des amis et on leur encore
ça serait de monter les qu'au lieu de
noël et on avait conscience qu'on
n'avait pas toutes les clés les tenants
et aboutissants d'une telle vie en
collectif et qu'avec m dépendent dit
gilles ans et en fait grâce à ce coup de
fil impromptue on avait trouvé en fait
quel était le meilleur tutoriel de une
immersion grandeur nature dans ces lieux
là et de faire un voyage au coeur des
écoliers hockey du coup lors vous à
super teese est beau à voir et qu'est ce
que c'est vraiment un écho lieu on va
essayer d'écrire ça et du mieux possible
un écolier on pourrait dire que c'est un
lieu où les habitantes et les habitants
expérimente ensemble en mode de vie
alternatif et sobre pour amener vers un
futur durable et soutenable ça ça peut
être un peu une définition larousse quoi
et avec sol et on a sorti un petit peu
de ces dix lieux où on est allé des
grands fondements qui font la nature de
ces lieux là
un premier grand principe on pourrait
dire c'est le partage et le respect par
on est là la protection de la nature et
tout ce qui est vivant en fait sur cette
planète c'est vraiment des notions
omniprésente à celle you like sont
primordiales ensuite ya le partage et la
solidarité la solidarité envers les
personnes du lieu les la nature ça et
puis aussi en prenant en compte les
problématiques sociétales de de tout
notre pays finalement
ensuite bella comment on s'organise en
collectif parce que convives tout seul à
2 à 5 à 10 30 ou même sens mais on
s'organise pas de la même manière et
dans ces lieux là on a vu qu'il faisait
et qu'ils expérimentent et la
gouvernance partagée ou gouvernance
horizontale contrairement à des fois
dans notre société qui est plutôt un
mode de vie
verticale donc voilà comment on
s'organise en groupe et en collectif
ensuite il ya le l'ancrage dans le
territoire donc comment on va créer du
lien avec tous les habitants habitante
sont le voisin et nos voisines en fait
comment créer du lien avec eux
même s'ils sont à côté de nous et
comment créer des projets de territoire
ensuite vient l'autonomie et ont ils
essayent de tendre vers une autonomie
alimentaire et énergétique ça me revient
pas à une autarcie ou quoi que ce soit
mais c'est réfléchir baho réfléchir en
matière de troc de circuits courts de
production sur le lieu d'un liant
conscience des problématiques d'échelle
qu'on a sur le territoire plus largement
et du coup en restant cohérent avec ce
qu'on produise on va échanger avec les
voisins etc et puis il ya un dernier
point qui est quand même assez important
et donc on commence à parler de plus en
plus c'est des technologies et des
moyens anciens et nouveaux qui sont
pensés pour être le plus durable
accessible et utile possible et dans le
jargon on appelle ça les low tech voilà
donc voilà là on vient de vous sortir la
recette magique pour créer votre super
écolieux j'espère que vous allez bien
pris des notes mais en tout cas ça
oubliez pas de rajouter de la musique de
la bonne humeur et l'enthousiasmé du
partage des personnes de toutes les
générations et de la bonne nourriture
est aussi ben ou pour un peu faire le
résumé de tous ces points là il ya une
phrase qui nous a beaucoup marqués
pendant le voyage c'est un écolier on
est allé en charente qui s'appelle loisy
du coq à l'âme est donc cette phrase qui
résume bien on trouve tous ces points
elle dit retrouver des compétences à
faire et à vivre ensemble dans
l'élégance de la sobriété heureuse pour
préserver notre environnement humain et
nourricier sauvegarder notre planète et
réenchanter le monde et une poupe ips ou
phrases et puis juste un dernier petit
point à rajouter à tout ça qui est
important à préciser encore plus ici
c'est de référencer de réfléchir à
comment
comment faire en fonction de ses
appétences plutôt que de ses compétences
on a tendance peut-être à l'oublier un
peu dans nos études mais faire en
fonction de nos appétence ça va
forcément plus nous amener vers
finalement faire les choses avec
enthousiasme et ça c'est super important
donc maintenant qu'on vous a présenté
tous ces points là on a aussi à travers
ce voyage vers marquer des points de
vigilance des points de vigilance donc
trois facteurs auxquels il faudrait
faire attention qui pourrait mettre en
péril la mise en place et la pérennité
de ces lieux là et ces vies en collectif
donc tout d'abord il ya le facteur
économique donc quand on rentre dans un
lieu et qu'un collectif se crée des fois
l'apport l'apport d'argent il va
énormément varié et des fois il peut
fermer les portes à certaines personnes
qui auront pas les moyens donc vraiment
hyper important de poser un cadre
comment comment le collectif organise
son mode économique
ensuite on parlait d'autre si rapidement
tout à l'heure ce qu'il ya de très
important c'est l'ancrage dans le
territoire et du coup être sûr que les
voisins les habitants des communes
alentours la communauté commune la
mairie avoir des bons d un bon
relationnel avec eux pour pas que le
lieu soit vu très rapidement comme une
secte de 35 personnes qui s'installent
là d'un coup qu'est ce qui nous veulent
et du coup avoir des bons rapports avec
eux et communiqué ça peut être vraiment
un facteur limitant si si c'est gens là
sont contre contre toute arrivée et le
dernier facteur le plus important
vraiment dans tous les lieux on est allé
on nous l'a redit on nous l'a redit
c'est le facteur humain le facteur
humain donc les relations entre les gens
du collectif est en fait c'est un
facteur qui est primordial et pour que
ça se passe bien il faut poser un cadre
de bienveillance et de sécurité où
chacun et chacune vont pouvoir
s'exprimer exprimé ses envies ses
besoins ses peurs tout ça pour qu'en
fait tout puisse se passer au mieux et
donc
la communication pour ça c'est vraiment
prêt centrale est primordial donc là on
vient de vous présenter les points
importants les points de vigilance
ensuite en terme de ressenti vois dans
mon quotidien tout ce qu'on a appris du
voyage et toutes les questions en fait
que le voyage a pu a pu nous faire
soulever se questionner bassam
accompagnent au quotidien donc
actuellement je ne vis pas dans un décor
lieu dans un appartement mais je me suis
bien rendu compte que le mode de vie
dans la grande ville ça me correspondait
pas forcément et que j'avais du mal à
trier toutes les sollicitations de temps
et est que mon énergie était un petit
peu dispersés partout et donc revoir
notre mode de vie au niveau plus local
et j'avais l'impression d'un corps en
quittant la grande ville est allée dans
une ville un peu à taille humaine quand
même c'était agréable de la traversée à
pied ou à vélo sans devoir prendre
forcément de métro que nos amis mais en
fait c'est nos voisins qu'on peut créer
des projets de territoire à l'échelle
d'un quartier où l'échelle d'une ville
et ça c'est satisfaisant de faire tout
ça et toutes les valeurs tirer de ce
voyage mais nous suivent au quotidien et
on peut avoir un peu un mode de vie
d'écolier 'sauver' dans un appartement
et pour ma part ben c'est un peu comme
solène depuis toujours pas dans un éco
lieu peut-être un jour on ne sait pas je
vis dans un appartement et j'ai pas
vraiment quitté la grande ville
mais ce voyage il m'a beaucoup
questionné hymne alimente encore au
quotidien à savoir où c'est que je veux
placer mon énergie ou c'est que je veux
placer mon temps c'est des questions
auxquelles on a été amené beaucoup à
répondre pendant notre voyage et que les
seuils de continuer à appliquer et me
dire bas où c'est que je veux mettre mon
temps et du coup l'equilibre que j'ai
trouvé cette année c'est de de
travailler dans des associations et de
m'impliquer dans tes projets qui vont à
la fois ben
visibiliser des alternatives qui vont à
mon sens dans le bon sens
défendre notre nature notre planète et
puis quand même
attaqué un petit peu faim participé à la
chute des grands pollueurs on va dire et
cet équilibre là ce questionnement au
quotidien ben il me convient et et pour
moi c'est appliquer un petit peu tout ce
qu'on a pu voir et ressentir pendant ce
voyage pour continuer de participer à
mon échelle à cette douce et joyeuse
révolution pour réinventer un petit peu
tous ces imaginaires la dombes et nous à
la fin de ce voyage avec gym watts on
s'est demandé quel pouvait être le but
commun de toutes ces personnes parce
qu'on a visité une dizaine de lieux mais
il y en a tellement tellement dans toute
la france et dans le monde et qu'est-ce
qui les poussait tous ces gens tout
c'est tous ces lieux toutes ces
histoires à se rassembler ensemble on
s'est dit qu'il faisait ça pour
expérimenter justement ensemble et en
fait mettre en commun et partager des
connaissances partagées des ressources
partager des savoir-faire
faire tout ça dans en fait dans dans la
création de nouveaux imaginaires et pour
expérimenter ensemble un mode de vie
plus sobres qui serait aussi plus lent
dans eqii scoci du coup plus agréable
dans la joie et aussi dans l'amour parce
que il ya une chose dont on est persuadé
avec solène c'est que chaque humaine et
chaque humain est capable d'aimer de
s'aimer soi d'aimer les autres et ce
voyage l'a fait que nous le confirmer
que l'amour il est présent partout mais
aujourd'hui avec les nombreuses
sollicitations le rythme de vie qui
s'accélère la routine du quotidien où le
travail où toutes ces choses là fait que
on peut un peu mettre de côté sa où la
qualité de l'amour se dégradent
peut-être et ses suites se re
questionner de se poser et se dire ok en
fait on est capable de s'aimer soi une
fois qu'on est capable de s'aimer soi on
va pouvoir aimer les autres et faire les
choses ensemble et avancer ensemble et
réfléchir ensemble à ces choses qu'on
pourrait mettre en place et et pour nous
c'est primordial de réfléchir à ça parce
qu'on est intimement persuadé qu' on est
tous capable d'aimer qui a pas de
problème là dessus
est aussi très important de bien
questionner ses besoins fondamentaux de
repenser sont vides et de se repenser
dans le rapport aux autres de quoi on a
vraiment besoin est et on pense aussi
qu'il est vraiment urgent vital de
revoir et de réinvestir tous nos
imaginaires et de prouver en fait qu'un
mode de vie sobre c'est pas contraignant
justement c'est agréable et c'est viable
en fait de dette sauf dans son quotidien
ça nous permet d'enlever énormément de
charge mentale que ça soit au niveau
environnemental social politique
économique et en fait quand on n'a pas
besoin de grand chose on va pas manquer
de beaucoup de choses et on sent si on
s'en sentira beaucoup plus humble et
apaisée
voilà on espère que c'est petit parole
vous auront permis un peu comme ça l'a
fait pour ce voyage de d'écouter un peu
nos enfants intérieur qui sont tout au
fond de nous parfois pour essayer avec
eux de réfléchir à comment on peut
réinvestir nos imaginaires ré-imaginer
toute la société dans laquelle on fait
partie et puis rêver tous ensemble et
avoir un peu d'espoir et voilà terminé
merci beaucoup merci au louvre
[Applaudissements]